this video is brought to you by fabulous
but friends in case you didn't hear
we've revamped our Rick and Morty
podcast squanch as a weekly stream right
here on YouTube and one comment that
keeps coming up in the chat is is Jerry
kind of cool now anything
fairies
indeed the first half of season six has
seen Jerry as the only family member not
to go to war with his night person night
Jerry and I write letters to each other
write a book explaining how to enjoy a
dinosaur-inflicted Utopia and even find
inner peace in some Dimension my life is
perfect Rick was always right everyone
needs to let go oh and he and Rick
finally became friends thanks friend in
fact ever since Rick's portal gun broke
at the end of season 5 the show is felt
more focused on Grounded familial
relationships and character growth in
the same way Jerry's gone from the
show's buffoon what the hell I know
right oh what the hell I know right to
its sort of moral Center Jerry said
night summer would appreciate it if
everybody could rinse off their plates
after eating what you know rinse the
Schmutz off after eating makes it easier
to clean up later while Rick has always
been the show's nihilist mascot Jerry's
softer side is introducing a surprising
counterbalance to the show's signature
cynicism namely sincerity so let's take
a closer look at the first six episodes
of the season to see how the show has
evolved and what we should expect from
the rest of this season let's dive into
this mid-season wisecrack Edition on
Rick and Morty is sincerity the new
cynicism okay but before we get into it
I want to tell you about this video
sponsor fabulous the number number one
self-care app to help you build better
habits and achieve your goals now if you
have difficulty sticking to new routines
and who doesn't or if you'd like to
improve your happiness on a daily basis
fabulous can be an excellent solution
it's a digital coach that uses
Behavioral Science to help you create
and stick to fresh new habits with
fabulous you can adopt a personalized
daily routine that can help you tackle
goals of any size if you want to
decrease stress increase productivity or
even my favorite drink more water every
day fabulous can help the app helps you
create rituals throughout the day
starting from the moment you wake up
these small steps help you ease into new
habits and can lead to long lasting
changes fabulous offers two programs to
choose from you got dedicated programs
or habit tracking with the dedicated
programs you're immersed in a multi-week
journey of guided self-discovery
fabulous will send you inspiring and
motivational letters and at the end of
each one you'll choose a positive action
for that week these new positive actions
are added to your daily routine and the
absence friendly reminders to help you
stick to them if you opt for the Habit
tracking approach you can go at your own
pace as you complete bite-sized tasks
and get gentle encouragement throughout
the day you can choose from 100 tasks
within the app or add your own and with
the fabulous premium account you can
track an unlimited number of habits and
access all the programs and exercises
the app has to offer like coaching
sessions and support circles so join the
community of more than 30 million users
around the world and start building your
ideal daily routine the first 100 people
who click on the link in the description
will get 25 off their fabulous
subscription and now back to the show
Rick and Morty has always been known for
its equal parts cynicism and nihilism
we've watched the characters die
numerous times seemingly without
ramifications because there's always
another version of each character in
Another Universe ready to step in we
bailed on that reality and we came to
this one because in this one the world
wasn't destroyed and and in this one we
were dead so we came here and and we
buried ourselves and we took their place
Rick's World View in which nothing and
nobody really matters and he's basically
a drunk God has largely been wedded to
the overall ethos of the show but this
season feels different the first episode
picks up where the last season left off
resulting in some typical Rick and Morty
Shenanigans but the adventures that
follow forced the characters to face
their Reckless past Morty learns that
his original Beth and summer died as a
result of his actions in the rickshank
Redemption we've spent a long time in
that ice a gentle mutant licked us out
but Beth got sick and summer didn't all
right and Rick ends up in a dimension
where he's haunted by a simulation of
his dead wife who guilts him for running
away from his past and not solving his
Beth's murder you always always do
everything you set your mind to except
keep your family alive at the same time
the episode also explores the
character's emotional needs summer bonds
with two versions of her mom especially
eager to impress space Beth and it
almost concludes in a self-consciously
cute family-oriented way what an amazing
joke I just told and also what an
adventure you know I guess it doesn't
matter where we're from if we're
together huh almost feels like my own
own family in that way you know we can
only get so close to cute and then
someone would mess it up of course
immediately after they have to bury
other dimensional corpses of themselves
but hey at least they do it as a family
the show seems to be consciously setting
us up to care about this specific
iteration of the Smiths along with space
bath it's okay if I come around
sometimes to emphasize that point it
also differentiates this version of Rick
from Rick Prime who doesn't care about
anything for you to be bait the guide
have to Value something he truly does
not give a [__]
he's the real deal this is important
because the show has long been defined
by the ease with which characters can be
killed off and revived and it's the
first hint of what's to come in this
season a surprising dash of sincerity
let's take a step back for some context
while the postmodern tendency and
culture was defined in large part by
cynicism and ironic distance Rumblings
about a new sincerity movement have been
brewing since it was used to describe
some 80s indie rock groups in Austin
Texas also forecasted by David Foster
Wallace and in 1993 essay the new
sincerity movement is characterized by
Earnest joyfulness and a rejection of
cynicism Foster Wallace writes the new
Rebels might be artists willing to risk
the yawn the rolled eyes the cool smile
the nudged ribs the parody of gifted
iron is the oh hell banal to risk
accusations of sentimentality melodrama
of over credulity of softness of
willingness to be suckered by a world of
lurkers and starers who fear gaze and
ridicule above imprisonment without law
some attribute the rise of cultural
sincerity which took place around 2002
to the 9 11 attacks which signaled what
Vanity Fair editor Grayden Carter called
The End of the Age of irony so in case
you thought Alanis Morissette ended the
age of irony
um it was actually Osama Bin Laden or
George Bush depending on who you believe
this could be interpreted to suggest
that sincerity tends to flourish during
times of collective pain or trauma in
which irony becomes increasingly
untenable and in case you're the guy who
loves irony if you're ever in a tense
situation you're trapped on an island
you uh you're being held hostage don't
be ironic then no one wants it if that's
true then you could expect the times
that we've all experienced over the last
couple of years to cause another Ripple
of new sincerity and that's exactly what
appears to have happened especially on
television as New York Times TV critic
James Pony wozak wrote in 2021 two
decades ago TV's most distinctive
stories were defined by a tone of ironic
Detachment today they're more likely to
be Earnest and direct he cites Ted lasso
as a prominent example of Comedy that
veers towards kindness and sincerity he
argues that two former Mainstays of
Television the anti-hero and the cringe
comedy simply became so widespread that
they developed their own cliches just
like the older moralistic shows they
reacted against as a result he writes
some of the most interesting stories
Helen on television is veering away from
irony and embracing earnestness and the
most recent season of Rick and Morty
seems to be doing just that and to give
you an example of sincerity before we
keep going I really appreciate all of
you our whole team appreciates all of
you and we love your support now if you
do want to support us besides things
like liking and subscribing which means
so much check out our patreon it is the
most direct way for you to support the
channel it helps us out a lot and you
get some fun perks videos early with no
ads some extra audio and video content
and access to our Discord server which
is fun and we have a whole Channel just
to talk about Rick and Morty so check it
out when you get a chance okay now back
to Rick and Morty without the infinite
possibilities of portal gun travel we
can fully invest in characters we've
come to know and care about which makes
the emotional Stakes feel higher and
episode 2 the show really starts digging
into the relationships and character
arcs of this distinct iteration of the
Smith family Rick and Morty worked
through their relation issues inside a
video game particularly via the part of
Morty that constitutes the very sincere
Marta we're 14 we like pizza and
masturbation we wear a yellow shirt and
we have hair that looks like a brown
helmet and we miss our family and we're
in way over our heads again it
culminates in Rick finally telling Morty
what he's always wanted to hear you
really are a good grandson you know that
I'm proud of you Morty from there
episode 3 revolves around Beth having a
fling with her clone space Beth who
represents an aspect of that self that
she's been alienated from an aspect that
she really admires Jerry overwhelmed by
Beth's uh self-love at first goes full
bug mode but eventually he learns quite
graphically to accept the Bolder more
intense aspects of his wife much to the
discomfort of Summer and Morty Jesus
Christ you need to fix the portal gun
right which I get because one time I
heard my parents had sex on the night
Princess Diana died and I can never
untether those two events it's like a
weird and vaguely uncomfortable metaphor
about the challenge of loving all the
messy complicated aspects of your
partner but the most interesting stuff
is what's going down with Jerry as we
mentioned in our video in episode 4 he's
the only member of the family who
doesn't wage an internal war against his
night self while the other streets are
night selves like indentured servants
Jerry treats the other part of himself
as a friend you two are being a couple
of Debbie down theirs wait until night
Jerry reads about this the show is
pointing out a surprising wisdom to the
usually bumbling dad he's the only one
really capable of self-compassion and
the only one not looking to
instrumentalize others for his own gain
Jerry's unexpected wisdom shines through
again in episode 6 dinosaurs turn the
world into a giant Utopia and nobody can
handle all the leisure time except for
Jerry so the family does something we
never thought we'd see they asked him
for advice how would you do it it's
finally happened and it turns out he's
written a book on his philosophy of
living a simple lazy life in both
episodes Jerry is the one best able to
thrive because of his uncomplicated
almost golden retriever lifestyle of
course he's not credited for the book
which the dinosaurs see as a collective
good and the significantly sours his
mood but the storyline still suggests
that Jerry is the one best able to exist
in a world that isn't driven by
productivity and consumption it's been
interesting to watch Jerry go from doofy
dad to someone who through innocence and
earnestness seems to have all the
answers or at least ask the right
questions like when he's the only one to
take the fortune cookie about him having
sex with his mom seriously leading him
and Rick to uncover a secret business
plot at the same time we watch Rick
disempowered without his portal gun and
haunted by the selfishness of his past
for example cloning his own daughter the
smartest man in the universe it seems
doesn't know anything about being happy
in a way if the show used to be a lot
lined with Rick's nihilist perspective
it's shifting towards Jerry's worldview
where kindness and family and friendship
are essential to living a good life
that's what makes episode 5 especially
interesting because it's basically a
buddy comedy between Rick and Jerry who
have become two opposite poles of the
show's worldview as we mentioned Jerry
is the only member of the family to take
his fortune seriously but once Rick
realizes the validity behind Jerry's
concerns he takes action to try to
prevent this edible fate while the two
engage in their usual bickering the
episode eventually ends with Rick giving
up the opportunity to control fate
itself in order to save Jerry from
having sex with his mother Jerry
responds with a sincere if buffoonish
move to thank Rick and declares them
friends thus fulfilling Rick's fortune
and ruining his immortality and yet in a
weird moment of genuine sweetness the
show seems to imply that Rick and Jerry
are indeed finally becoming friends it
feels like through Rick's growth and
decision to act with the show is
reconciling its old nihilism with its
new sincerity don't get us wrong we love
cynicism nihilism and ironic distance as
much as the next Rick and Morty fan but
this subtle shift in the show's ethos
feels really fitting for this moment we
live in an era of profound cynicism with
folks experiencing widespread distrust
in political institutions and all-time
high levels of distrust and pillars of
society ranging from the media to
organized religion from the criminal
justice system to public schools to
Consumer Brands and if we can't trust
Brands what do we do I love Brands as
shared truths seem to be collapsing
seeing a show like Rick and Morty
pivoting towards sincerity feels like
something of an antidote it arguably
speaks to our Earnest need as a society
to be able to believe in something even
if it's as simple as
good to be nice to your night person but
because this is Rick and Morty we can't
get too comfortable in a fitting end to
the first half of the Season Rick fixes
his portal gun and immediately sends
Morty to a bunch of different dimensions
it feels perhaps like it could be a hard
reset for the season ushering in a
future filled with the ironic Detachment
that initially made us fall in love with
the show so maybe the show is going to
make us feel like idiots for believing
that these characters could change or
maybe in a vein similar to a show Like
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
they're gonna pull off a balancing act
between the show's chaotic nihilism and
a new era of personal growth and
sincerity and we really hope they can do
this without making us think about
incest ever again you know between this
and House of the Dragon it's like I
don't need this in my life but what do
you all think season 6 shifting Rick and
Morty's guiding philosophy is the return
of the portal gun a return to cynicism
and you prefer a more sincere Rick and
Morty please let us know in the comments
and when the season starts back up we
will be squanching again on our Rick and
Morty be live stream the Squatch every
Monday thanks so much again for being
here check out our patreon if you
haven't and as always follow us on tick
tock on Instagram and Twitter and follow
me on Twitter if you want you know it's
fun why not and most importantly thank
you so much sincerely for watching we'll
see you later
[Music]
[Applause]